[Music]
thank you thank you
and i'm happy to take questions if
that's you i'm supposed to do nance
whatever you want me to do
joe biden finally made his way out of
the basement at least for a few minutes
it seemed
only to be abruptly cut off for wanting
to take questions
fox news contributor leo duarell and
host of the rumor report dave rubin join
me now
you know what i i'm just going to let
you guys hit it i mean
nance if you want me to take questions i
will the guy's the president of the
united states
this week he even said what am i doing
here
go ahead leo you go you know if i if i
thank you because i'm really bothered by
this you know he needs to put on his big
boy pants i want to see joe biden
at a state of the union i don't want to
see kamala harris on the left i don't
want to see jill biden
the american public has the right to see
joe biden stand up on his own two feet
take questions from fox and from
conservative outlets
and tell us what is in his mind this is
not the same joe biden in 2012
and 2016. i'm not playing doctor but he
doesn't look
strong he doesn't look like he has the
energy and i think the american public
needs to know
is he really controlling the white house
or is he just being propped up
by all these white house circuits that's
what really concerns me
yeah go ahead dave yeah look jeanine
that's the key point is joe biden in
charge or is
nance or some other string puller in
charge i mean there is obviously
something cognitively wrong with joe
biden i don't take any pleasure in that
he wasn't my
candidate but but the leader of the free
world obviously is having cognitive
problems they don't want him taking
questions
literally i mean you just said this
earlier in the week he said he didn't
know what he was doing there
the guy is is messed up and and it's
it's an extraordinary scandal if you
think about it because everyone knows it
and yet we're not allowed to talk about
it i've been saying for about a year the
scandal
is not that he has cognitive problems
the scandal is the non-scandal in that
nobody
will talk about it except people on fox
and and people that are on youtube
or podcast or that sort of thing
you know
the amazing thing is that if he has to
communicate with world
leaders now we're hearing that kamala
harris
is communicating with world leaders what
does she know
we didn't elect her for this i mean it's
just a question of time before the
trojan horse disappears
and she's the president am i right leo
you're 100 right what does kamala harris
know nothing
nothing we did not elect her as
president and she is
every time judge i see president biden i
see kamala harris as if she's there just
waiting for the opportunity if joe biden
got elected for president still
questionable
let him go to a state of the union give
a
solo press conference i don't want to
see kamala harris or jill biden
on the left or right flank let this man
stand up on his own two feet
put on the big boy pants
you know what i don't even think it's a
question of the big boy pants dave i
think he should put on his baby pants
now the guy's regressing
he's done with the big boy pants i mean
i'm worried about this country well look
no no no no for i mean joking aside this
is this is serious stuff
if he is supposed to be the leader of
the free world which the president of
the united states i think is supposed to
be
then you'd want someone that cognitively
cognitively was all there
look hillary clinton obviously knows it
barack obama knows it the democratic
leadership knows it and also to your
point on kamala harris let's not forget
she was polling basically at zero in her
own party in the primaries
when she got out so in effect the
president the upcoming president of the
united states
because we all know it's going to happen
was polling at zero with her own people
so so what does that tell you so this
this we can joke about it but it really
is
stuff right now well i got to tell you
guys you know the person pulling the
strings
it just seems to me that it's obama
because someone's back there and obama
always liked uh kamala harris and but
that's for another discussion leo
terrell dave reuben we love you guys
thanks for being remembered
remember that interview thank you i do
i do if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell